Whales in Hesse and Bavaria?
Is this this climate döns yet,
state elections?
I hate elections
just because you can't make it
to carry out your only accident-free operation.
No man,
because there are these grinsepeters hanging around everywhere
and disfigure the city
as OB one could still somehow disfigure Berlin.
I love politicians on election posters.
Why?
They are portable,
don't talk stupid stuff and are easy to remove.
Why find
State elections actually do not all take place at the same time,
so that at least every 5 years
is also once reported about you?
Hey,
at least the Saarland is not threatened
Massively many agitators
by the AfD in the state parliament.
Rush!
So
with me no deputy prime minister was
in his youth
with anti-Semitic leaflets in school satchel
caught.
As in the GDR.
There weren't even satchels back then.
Now let's be clear,
with you parties are up for election,
who want to get out of Germany with Bavaria,
but that's what we all wish for.
Huh?
Hey, tell me,
what kind of weird plane is that?
Man?
That's! Oh,
it's just the barrels,
who is constantly between her job as Minister of the Interior
and their election campaign in Hesse.
Why doesn't she take the track?
This is much more environmentally friendly for Deutsche Bahn.
Huh?
It's not Aus.
What can you not even make 1 video
without bashing me?
Thank you
I am most surprised,
that he arrived on time
to stop the joke against him.